today not a single Republican candidate
announced or potential is clearly and
consistently supporting a path to
citizenship not one no I'm not talking
about amnesty any means and I said the
reason for that is over time I deduce
you said you supported in my view has
changed what you would get is the
equivalent of a non-immigrant
non-permanent work visa to be in the US
and you would have to be in that status
for a significant period of time that
you earn legal status over a long period
of time will you pay a fine we pay taxes
you don't receive government assistance
citizenship they talk about legal status
that is code for second-class status for
the vast majority of people who are here
we will give you a path to legalization
if you meet the following conditions pay
a fine because you entered illegally be
willing to pay back taxes over time try
to learn English and we have to help you
do that because we've cut back on so
many of those services and then you wait
in line